All right, stop right there.
I have been asked about this
particular scene so many times,
and they want to know how we
train to be able to do that.
We don't.
All right, there is so much stuff
that is incorrect in this.
What's going on? My name is Andy Stumpf.
I spent just under 17
years as a US Navy SEAL,
and I host the "Cleared Hot" podcast.
Today, we're going to be taking a look
at some underwater
action scenes from movies
and seeing how real they really are.
One last thing. When you hit the water,
don't forget to cut away your chute.
90% of people killed during the HALO jump
got tangled up in their
chutes and drowned.
I've never been in an
underwater fight in my life
with anybody or thing
except for my own equipment.
My belts have tried to kill me.
Magnets have tried to kill me. Hoses.
Like, you end up fighting
all of your gear.
So that portion of the brief was legit.
I've never seen anybody
give an audible brief on an airplane,
'cause it's so loud that you can't hear.
I am not aware of any
real-world operations
that started with a
parachute jump of any kind
that went directly into a dive.
You're probably going to do a jump
where you're pushing boats
out of the aircraft as well.
The boat lands under its own parachute,
you land next to it,
you get into the boat.
And you're probably
going to have to travel
a substantial distance
to actually do the dive.
Because otherwise you're
flying an airplane
directly over the top of where
you're trying to be sneaky,
and that's not how you play
varsity-level hide-and-seek, right?
Cutting away from your parachute
before you get into the water
is actually really dangerous,
because at lower altitudes,
it's really hard to judge
how high you are up above the water.
The rule that we use:
Wait until your body hits the water
to cut away from your equipment.
There have been people who cut away
and they thought they were at 10 feet,
but they were at 100 feet or 150 feet.
And at some point,
the surface tension of
water can be like concrete,
and [claps] you can kind of do the math.
You don't have to use a flare.
I mean, they make flashlights.
They last longer.
You don't have to worry
about getting burned.
People would actually probably
be a little bit underwhelmed
with the type of diving that
you do in the SEAL teams.
Not by the volume of diving,
but it's very focused
on getting from A to B.
A lot of it is navigation
to a place where you could
implant a charge or a sensor,
and then you're right back out.
People who do this type of diving
or the type of diving where
they're out on coral reefs,
it's just a total different experience.
Most of the diving that I did was at night
and at depths less than 20 feet.
Not accurate at all. This is a zero.
They actually did some really
robust breath-holding work for this movie.
And it's easy to get a long breath hold.
Like, there are people
who can hold their breath
for, like, five, six,
seven, eight minutes.
It's about the lowest
level of exertion, though.
You don't see people holding their breath
being incredibly active, which
is exactly what he was doing.
[choking]
The first introduction to
diving for SEAL candidates
is open circuit in the pool.
And I administered the test,
and it would not be
uncommon to watch students
have a shallow-water blackout
or hold their breath until they pass out.
And one of the main indicators
that somebody is actually
about to become unconscious
is that bubbles will start
escaping their mouth,
just like he simulated in the movie.
So they actually obviously
put their time in
to research this.
For the cinematic aspect
and the actual likelihood
of this happening,
we're going to give them, like, a 3.
And your muscles will stop
working in about 30 seconds.
Nah, I'm sure it's not that fast.
Would you please listen for once?
So, this apparently is
occurring in the Arctic.
His operational equipment consisted of
a pair of board shorts
and what appeared to be
a messenger bag slung over his shoulder,
which is a controversial choice.
You spend a good portion of your time
as a student in BUD/S hypothermic.
I mean, we're talking
laying in the Pacific Ocean
down in San Diego.
Sometimes the water
temperature's in the 60s.
We can get you hypothermic
by keeping you in there long enough,
but that's a different type of cold
than what was being shown in "Archer."
Like, that's Arctic-water cold.
Looked like he was putting a
mason glass explosive charge
somewhere inside of the propeller.
OK. I mean, highly improbable.
The propeller itself may not be
the best place to actually put a charge.
Actually, when we would do ship attack,
combat sweeper operations,
instead of actually the propeller itself,
the underside of a vessel,
there's oftentimes struts
and then the driveshaft that
goes out to the propeller.
And we would actually put the
charges on the struts itself
to structurally damage the ship's ability
to work under its own power or navigate.
If you blow up a propeller,
and I'm not saying that this
is like a NASCAR swap-out fix,
but you can put another propeller on.
If you damage the structural
integrity of the ship
and then the propeller
shaft is then broken
and they have no ability to reattach that,
again, it's a fixable
problem, but now we're talking
probably taking the boat out of the water,
putting it into a dry dock,
and all of those things.
So you can get more bang for your buck.
Pun intended, I suppose.
How explosives are able
to work underwater?
A lot of them are naturally
very resistant to the elements.
C-4 is a good example.
To get C-4 to explode, we
actually use blasting caps.
So that functions underwater, though,
just like it would in the air.
Tough to rate a cartoon,
I think, for accuracy.
This is going to have
to be on the lower end.
I'm going to go with a 2.
And the only reason he gets a 2
is I like the homemade mason charge
that he somehow wedged into the propeller.
If you need to cross the
river, cross the river.
You know, there's no
reason to actually pop up
in the middle of it and give
away your tactical advantage
if you are trying to sneak up on somebody.
You would either cross the
entire thing above the water
or cross the entire thing below the water.
Or go farther down or upstream
and maybe find a log that's across it,
so you don't have to get wet.
'Cause being wet sucks.
All right, stop right there.
I have been asked about this
particular scene so many times,
because people absolutely love it
and they want to know how we
train to be able to do that.
And here's the answer:
we don't.
Because, right, you would never
fall in any other direction.
You just absolutely know
the exact place and time
that somebody is going to fall
when you shoot them in the head, right?
Because why wouldn't you?
What could possibly go wrong?
But you've got to remember,
all of that was preceded by
probably a 7.62 or a 0.300 Win Mag round
snapping through the jungle.
The suppressor that's on the rifle,
it's basically a muffler.
And it contains some of the gas,
and it drastically reduces the
decibel output of the rifle.
But bullets,
when they fly through the air,
they're supersonic, so it makes a crack.
And there is subsonic ammunition,
and it's much quieter.
That's not what that person was shooting.
The whole point of doing the charade
of catching somebody and
lowering them into the water
as if it was just eating
them into the abyss
is 'cause you're trying to be sneaky.
So going through all of
this in attempt to be sneaky
and then cracking off
a round in the jungle,
it defeats the entire purpose.
It's just, there's so,
it's not how it works, people!
Where you link up with a submarine
in the middle of the ocean,
that's totally plausible.
They were on a Zodiac,
which is going to have
probably a 55- or a 35-horsepower engine.
So they could easily go from
a landmass over the horizon
out into international water,
or really wherever the sub
would want to meet and do that.
So that's totally legit.
Yeah. Wow.
So, they obviously had direct support
from the United States
Navy to make this movie.
And I'm actually surprised they
showed very much of the SDV,
which stands for SEAL Delivery Vehicle.
In essence, it is a miniature submarine.
It's smaller, harder to be discovered,
and you can move people and equipment
a really far distance and then
go back to the submarine too,
'cause you can go back and relink back up
to that asset that you departed from.
You are in your dive gear
until that dive is over,
and it can be up to 14 hours.
A lot of the times you're in dry suits.
Dry and warm are two very different things
that people should not confuse.
They nailed it. It's very plausible
that all of that would
occur on an SDV operation.
I'm going to give them a 10 on that.
The sniper water river catch is a zero.
It actually might be a negative number.
Is there a more obvious way
to let somebody know that you're coming
than white and orange
parachutes in the daytime,
jumping directly over the top of them?
"Surprise! You didn't see that coming!"
I've worn dive fins on my
feet for a free-fall jump
and actually was falling
through the air with them on.
More often than not, though,
the back strap of the fin,
you put your feet through that,
and you actually tape
the fin up to your leg.
But if you're going to land in the water,
you're going to want to have fins on you
in case you need to
have the ability to swim
or exert yourself.
You're going to need those fins.
[laughs]
Yes!
And they had a fleet,
a full fleet of submersibles
with spear guns.
I am not aware of any engagement
at any time in the history of human beings
where anything like this has occurred.
We are not trying to get
into fights in the water.
Like, bottom line.
We use it as a way to
disguise what we're doing
or to get from A to B
or to be sneaky, right?
Like, "Well, I don't
know where they went."
Like, "Bloop, here we
are! We're in the water.
You didn't see us, surprise!"
We're not looking to
get into a fight, ever.
So, no.
We're not bringing tridents or spears
or any of that stuff.
I like how they're cutting the hoses.
Unfortunately, there is
usually an inhalation hose
and an exhalation hose,
and they probably could still breathe
if they cut the wrong one.
We always had dive knives on us,
but it's for cutting gear
if something gets hung up.
There was never a
thought in my mind, ever,
of pulling that out with the
intent of fighting with it.
It was for anything but that.
Like, Phillips-head screws,
using the tip of your knife,
like, that's what we use dive knives for.
I like the idea of what
he's got in his mouth.
I'll call that the gen-one Spare Air.
Which, with a canister of that size,
I feel like you have about
one-half of one breath.
So he certainly wouldn't
be able to stay underwater.
And then the concussive
device in the water.
Concussion in the way that
shock waves travel underwater
is a very, very real thing.
Let's just say that was
a grenade of some kind.
That would probably kill the people
inside of that contained area,
but it probably would
damage him a little bit too.
Especially if there's open
windows and portholes,
'cause that stuff will bounce out as well.
So it's plausible,
but I would say you would
want to get the [beep]
out of there before that thing went off.
Like, out of the water
before that thing went off.
I don't even know if I can give
this one a technical review.
So, I didn't get a good look at the gun
that he shot that out
of. My guess would be
probably some version of
the M203 grenade launcher.
The projectile doesn't have this
continuous propellant,
like it did in that, and
it just pushes along.
And people, I'm sure, want to know
if you can fire guns underwater.
You can fire a gun generally one time.
They're not designed to
function in an environment
that has that much
feedback from the water.
You could probably shoot a 203 underwater,
but it's not going to look like that.
It would probably come out of the barrel,
if it even cleared the barrel,
and then just drop right off.
And they also arm by spinning.
That's why it has a
minimum arming distance,
usually of 33 yards.
So there's a lot of things
that were completely impossible
in that particular scene right there.
If you just look at how inefficient
the swimming motion was.
What kills a lot of your energy,
there's two things.
One, they had a weapon slung around them
that was very loose,
and their shoes.
It is so hard to swim with shoes.
I think that video highlighted
the difference between fins and no fins.
That's what swimming looks like
when you don't have fins
on and you have shoes.
That's why you want to
have fins on top of that.
If we were jumping and there wasn't
going to be that much swimming,
I'd go with one that
had maximum flexibility,
so I could tape it up and wear the thing
as I was leaving the aircraft.
If I had to wear what they had on,
I'd be pulling myself along the floor.
I think it would be easier,
and it's very positive,
and you'd get more
mileage for your effort.
That's why you need a
knife in that situation.
But they weren't diving,
so they didn't have their
dive knives with them.
However, they had a bunch of guns.
I mean, they didn't spend
5 bucks on a pocketknife?
I mean, what's going on here?
I'm going to give them a 3 at best.
It's a stretch. They're reaching for a 3,
but I'll give them a 3.
I found door No. 3. And I'm taking it.
Oh, that's a national treasure, all right.
You know, jumping off of a,
I think it was the aircraft carrier,
that's probably going to be 50, 60 feet.
I'm here for that. That's
definitely survivable.
You could definitely do that.
So, we navigated with,
we call them nav boards,
and we had three really
exciting items on there
that we used to get to stare
at for hours at a time.
The first one you already
mentioned. Was a compass.
The next entertaining
tool was a depth gauge,
and, lastly, a stopwatch.
That was it.
We dive in pairs, but only one person
gets the navigation board.
So somebody else out there is just like,
"I hate my life. This
dive is taking forever.
I don't even have anything to look at."
So sometimes when I was the buddy,
I would just swim on top of my dive buddy
and just look at the navigation board too
because I was so bored.
I just wanted to look at numbers
slowly just, like, creeping around.
Sadusky: Can you see Gates in the water?
Sir, it's the Hudson. Nothing is visible.
So, all these people that
are above them looking down
are going to see the bubbles.
This would be an example
of where closed circuit
would be better than open circuit.
Because even if that guy
grabbed him right underwater,
every time they exhale,
the bubbles are coming up.
It's actually really easy
to track divers' progress
from above when they're
breathing open circuit.
'Cause open circuit you
can see the bubbles,
closed circuit you can be sneaky.
So it's just a closed-loop system
that only allows the gas to
flow through in one direction,
because obviously you wouldn't want it
coming back and forth.
And you push it through
a chemical scrubber,
it pulls out the carbon
dioxide, and, boom,
you're off and running.
There's a 100% chance that
you could actually do that.
But if you wanted to do it
and actually not be seen,
I'd say closed circuit is a better option.
I'll give him a
7.
Bond: Conserve your gas supply.
Speak only when necessary.
Going to have to be a radio.
There's no way it's going to
be a Bluetooth connection.
I have no experience with doing that.
There's not really anybody
that you would be talking to,
nor do I know what you would
necessarily talk about.
The diving that we did
was hand-signal-based.
Or you'd have a grease pencil
and a piece of plastic,
and you could write on it.
Other than that, it was squeezes
or just [blabbing].
And it's amazing actually how much
you can learn what the
other person is saying.
You're almost actually
holding a conversation.
So, very low speed.
Even if something went wrong,
the No. 1 thing you do
is you stop the dive
and you go to the surface,
'cause you can take the stuff
out of your mouth and be like,
"Hey, man, what's going on?"
And you can restart the dive.
Yeah, that's real. Sharks
like to go in stuff too.
When things would bump into me,
the theory that I went with
was if I don't look, it didn't happen.
So we would be swimming around
a lot of times at night,
and then I would get slammed,
and my whole thought process was,
"Nope, I'm not gonna look at that.
I'm gonna pretend that it didn't happen."
It probably was, like, a sea lion.
You know, it could have been a dolphin.
It might've been a shark.
I don't know. I didn't look.
I would say that everything that they did
is possible.
They may not have had all
the right equipment to do it,
but I'll give it a 7.
So, it requires different equipment.
Oftentimes, even to get
into these cave systems,
it's a very high-risk,
high-consequence activity.
Hard pass.
Stay calm! We're going to buddy breathe.
They decided that they were
going to buddy breathe,
which is just basically
sharing one apparatus
between two people.
If you're going to do that,
you're going to have to do
more than just sit there
and buddy breathe until
your oxygen or air is gone.
Because you notice they were staying
in exactly the same spot.
So you could just sit there and do that
and then run out of air and die together,
or maybe buddy breathe
and start making your way
towards how you can get
the [beep] out of there.
Buddy breathing
can kind of go exactly
like it went in this movie.
People's ability to hold their breath
varies greatly.
And when the regulator is in your mouth
or the mask is on your
face and you're breathing,
you feel a lot better
than the person who is
holding their breath,
watching you breathe,
wishing that they were breathing,
wanting the mask that you're wearing.
So it can become a little bit of a battle,
but you have to work together.
You follow the procedure,
regardless if you're scared,
cold, wet, hungry, tired,
fill in the blank. Or
everything in between.
People can get very emotionally involved
in those situations, where
what they really need to do
is procedurally work through it,
as opposed to allowing
their emotions to take over.
And you have to work as a team.
Yeah. It would be one of
the worst-case scenarios
to have something happen like that.
Not the way that I would
want to go out, for sure.
I'm going to give that a 7.
So, if you liked this video
and you want to see more,
do me a favor and click the
link that's above my head.